i am sure any new muslim who
has tattoos or they had a previous
relationship or they have
a a habit which they find hard to kick
like drinking or whatnot i'm sure they
know what they need to do with their
life
right i'm pretty sure because they made
the choice to say allah and they
sacrificed a lot
so i don't think they need a reminder in
terms of these other types of things
[Music]
[Music]
there was a guy who asked a chef he was
an atheist by the way how are you going
to feel if
you die and you find out that you know
there's no day of judgment there's no
heaven and how are you gonna feel
and the chef answered i'm not gonna feel
as bad as you would when you find out
there is
and at the end of the day i'm not saying
religion is fear-mongering islam is
fear-mongering but if you don't want to
have fear
of a love your creator and you want to
be logically sold on religion there's a
lot of intellectuals ham desources
muhammad hijab
there's too many people subor ahmed too
many great scholars too many great
advocates of the truth
too many great cosmologists too many
great physicists too many great
even students of knowledge like rami
that are just out here doing
their due diligence open your eyes and
insha allah god willing
you are guided to see the truth but
allah does not change the condition of a
person until they change what's within
themselves
so if you guys don't change what's
within you you're not going to get
allah's guidance you're not going to get
that
podcast in the dunya the three muslims
podcast today we're joined with a very
special guest
to share the stage with you today to
have you on to be able to discuss
um because allah you're somebody who i
have been watching for a while
especially when it comes to dawah
to uh to the non-muslims you know people
who deal with
you know uh talking about secularism and
human rights you have to debate with
cosmic skeptic and all of that
so my first question would be how would
one approach dawah to non-muslims and
how does it differ
when giving dawah to muslims very good
question so firstly
thank you for inviting me here um i
think i think it's always a very good
format when you have a bunch of people
talking together rather than
people talking and um especially
nowadays that you know
people like these longest or segments
where you get a lot out and you guys had
hamza and
other really good guests as well so may
allah make this grow and
help this you know channel flourish
inshallah
so i think where to begin
first is you know you always start with
why
you know why do not do something so
if your why is correct then your how and
your what
fall into place so i think if we go back
to
what is islam islam is essentially
a relationship between the creation and
the creator a relationship which is pure
which is not affected by associating
partners with god calling upon other
than god
you know all of our love hope fear trust
you know everything sacrifice is for god
alone
so if we truly understand islam
then dawa is something which is just
part and parcel of that
picking up from you know
the stories of the prophets what do we
see we see the prophets go to the
nations they discuss with them they
articulate islam to them so
you know sometimes when i find people
who make a
you know demarcation between okay
practicing islam and you know that was
an additional thing
or you know dawa is is seen as something
uh almost like you know okay it's just
like a
extra thing that we do i always find
this very strange because
firstly if you have the
uh the ability to say la ilaha life you
have that blessing
that's only because your ancestors or
you were given the message
so for you to think that it's not your
duty to go passing on to others i would
say you actually don't understand your
own
genealogy how you were muslim in the
first place so
you know we have brothers from different
parts of the world uh here as well
and you know if you go back to why
you're muslim
you know it's very interesting how islam
spread however through the centuries
what we find is that
this job of conveying islam
became obsolete not obsolete as in
the duty of it but as in the muslims
just didn't do it
muslims live next to uh many people who
they didn't give the message of islam to
and later on
you know we find this in in the history
of islamic empires as well that
you know those people when they left
um you know like for example the
ottomans left the greek territories
we find the mughals that their you know
their empire
crumbled and and you know we also have
you know the muslims in northern nigeria
who didn't evangelize to the muslims
uh to the people in the south what we
find is that other people came in
and you know sadly we find that in the
greek territories
you know all sorts of things um uh have
taken place like for example
ottoman mosques in uh have been
converted or destroyed in fact there was
one ottoman mosque
uh which was uh turned into a theater
and what was really sad was it was
actually a theater that
held adult type productions you know
really
sick stuff and when we go back again to
uh the mughal empire we we find that you
know there are people who simply
still don't know what islam is and
likewise i
was really sad when i was in northern
nigeria
is that even though alhamdulillah
there's a lot of great brothers and
organizations
and people who are giving dawa there now
um
many people in the north and and this is
me speaking to
people from the the hausa uh tribe and
you know they admit
that actually they didn't
help others to accept islam and what we
find is that the christians came in
and some very startling
some very startling and and interesting
figures that
between 1885 and 2020
christianity grew by 50-fold in africa
50-fold and southern africa
which was mainly indigenous african
belief
um they became christian and even some
of the muslims
uh you know in the areas where there was
a mixture like malawi and you know these
sort of central african places
what we find is that you know muslims
converted to christianity as well
because the muslims we didn't have
enough knowledge about islam
and also the christians came in with
their education with their hospitals
with their schools with all these types
of things
and we don't talk about this as a
tragedy that there are millions
of people alive today who are actually
christian
but their ancestors were muslim like
this is
something which you know we don't talk
about but is this not a tragedy is this
not a
loss of a large part of the ummah and if
you go back to
you know these types of places like we
visit like malawi
you you go to a village you speak to and
this is not anecdotal this is me
on the ground and i've seen this myself
you are somebody
you know what um what uh what's your
name and a christian
uh would say hassan a christian would
say khadijah
this is this is incredible that
our religion is a religion which is very
evangelical
which is actually right from the
beginning a religion which is there to
actually
engage with other world views and have
these dialogues
yeah muslims are passive and they
they're very meek
you know alhamdulillah people like
sheikah madida came forward to try and
wake us up
i would say there's a lot of work to be
done in in terms of the dao
yeah subhanallah it's it's amazing that
you bring this up because me and phide
were actually in the class yesterday and
we were talking about you know
what is islam and a lot of the time
people are like this they say the five
lives just let me know we pray we fast
and
that's it it's like well if you look at
the sahaba radical
on whom like this was sent to i believe
najashi
his answer was you know we were we're
basically we were messed up people islam
came and fixed us you know and other
sahabi they mentioned
it's to feed the poor or even allah in
the quran mentions
you know uh people who feed the poor or
people who don't feed the poor
are kuffar and so on and so forth and
islam is so much more than we believe
this and we pray
it is this this propagation of this
belief this is
not that this is a way this is the way
in that we must teach people
with beautiful character with the upmost
beautiful character like the prophet
allah
and it's amazing because i actually
reminded me i believe it was a statistic
that i heard of when talking to a few um
reverts for a reaver program that they
were working on
it was something like i don't want to
give a number but majority of reverts
actually leave islam they leave the fold
of islam after reverting
and that's that brings another layer to
a problem that we have with the
passiveness from muslims whereas we get
them in the door and it's okay now it's
like
survival of the fittest staff but
you say survival of the fetus but
survivor of the fittest would be
charitable i would say there's sometimes
an active
um not witch hunt but this very negative
attitude
towards you know like an oppression yeah
yeah
absolutely i mean uh sorry to interject
but i just remembered something that
happened literally down the road so down
the road
from where this uh office is and there's
plenty of mustards here so no one will
work out which mustard
it is i saw this myself i went to go
pray in the masjid
and um this guy walked uh
into the masjid with his shoes on and he
literally just just came into the
entrance
and this pakistani uncle came out and
started shouting him how can you walk
into the mosque with the shoes on and
he's a non-muslim guy and he said can i
have a copy of the quran
and the the uncle uh said to him
we don't have a copy i was like whoa
what is going on here so i finished my
prayer i came out and i said to him i'm
looking really
just don't worry about this i'm gonna go
get a copy of the quran from my house
english copy give it to you and i spoke
to him a little bit
and i said to him um because he he was
on a lunch break or something
and you know subhanallah this guy had
polio or he had some sort of problem
and um he was a catholic or a christian
of some sort and it was actually hard
for him to walk but he walked to the
masjid and that's the way he was treated
so i said to him okay so if you come
back at this time
i'm going to bring you a copy and i also
took his number
and i was just like in pain i was in
pain how can a non-muslim
walking into a masjid be shouted at
because he was wearing shoes and
be be told by somebody leading the
prayers
that he wasn't the imam but he's
somebody who sometimes leads the prayers
that
no we don't have a copy of the quran um
so
what happened is i went home um i got it
and uh you know i i i think i text him
as well in between that look i'm gonna
be coming at this time
i came back and the guy never turned up
and i still remember that to this day so
it's not just that
non-muslims are treated badly and new
muslims are are neglected
um it's almost as if
we are so far away from understanding
the importance of dawa
we have no idea how to treat new muslims
new muslims should be treated as
princes as princes and and and you know
princesses and
you know we should be laying out the red
carpet for them
you know but if you look at the horror
stories that reverts go through
especially the reverts who are
you know um uh in in areas in which
there
there's a lot of cultural strong islam i
say
there's a there's a culture the culture
of islam is stronger
as in do you have those countries with a
particular type of culture which is
not exactly in line with islam they get
treated
quite badly right so i think it's very
important to be candid about these
issues
yeah yeah for the addition 100 100
i um i haven't heard many of these
horror stories or experienced it myself
but i think that that you know maybe
that's another layer of the issue
you know we don't talk about it but um
like 100 it's it's found a lot
but okay so my next question would be
what do we do as muslims who know this
problem to bring awareness to other
muslims and what do they do to make the
issue better
okay the first thing we need to
understand is
we all love the sunnah the prophet
sallam you have to love the sunnah you
have to i mean
why why do we grow a beard we grow a
beard not because this is cool obviously
it is but um it's because we believe in
the prophets and we believe that what
they did we need to
follow them in every step
but the prophets were conveying islam
what do we find amongst all of the
prophets in the quran we
find salam and ibrahim al-islam and musa
alayhi islam and the prophet
isa al-islam all of the prophets we
don't find that allah mentions their
prayers and allah mentions these things
in details
what you find amongst all of them is
that they were calling their
nations so if we're gonna have beards if
we're gonna do the other stuff
which is very important why wouldn't we
do something that
all of the prophets did so i'm not
afraid of saying this and there may be
some muslims and some muslims actively
discourage dawa and they say silly
things like
you know we need to get our own house in
the order uh we can't do this and no we
need to wait for i don't know
you know people have weird ideas the
fact is
if you do not give dawah if you do not
support those who give dawah if you do
not facilitate
the da'wah if you do not have your heart
in the dao if you are not even concerned
about the dawah then i would say you
don't understand islam and
this particular clip please if anybody
disagrees take this
and absolutely refute me i'm ready to
debate this till the cows come home
if you do not believe in the dawah
you do not understand islam oh there's
oh if more people come to islam what are
we going to do you know muslims are
doing
this or that that's ridiculous all of
these excuses are ridiculous the fact is
if you believe something is true why
wouldn't you share it
and if we look back at the history of
islam
there are points in which they were
amazing african duart and
asian art and other who through their
small efforts
literally entire societies
changed right even we have amazing
people like uh sheikh abdulrahman sumath
who went to africa and you know so many
people accepted islam
where people uh you know in uh there's a
there's a guy
who um uh in in in pakistan he's
he was a hindu he converted to uh islam
in the sindh region then he started
going from village to village and
you know getting people to you know hear
the message of islam and many people are
accepting with him
so we have these pockets of these
amazing people right
and what i also find sometimes strange
is that muslims would love
to be you know they would love some sort
of
even online these sort of online dramas
in these onlines or conflicts right
so they would love to be you know if i
make a video
right saying you know these three
muslims yeah i swear you know these guys
you know brother i swear they're funded
by the mi5 or cia
and that's it that video will go viral
but if i say you know
since 1885 to 2020 christianity
grew by 50 fold yet the african
population grew by six-fold
and many many muslims are converting to
christianity in africa
that view that video probably get
watched by five people and two jinns
no one cares but we don't understand
islam that's the problem
we we focus on trivialities and we don't
understand the importance
of this message of islam if you don't
understand
islam then of course you will not
understand the importance of dao
100 so there's something else that we
talked about because what
it's amazing because this was the like
the first few classes
of the entire like like like dabble
program this is literally the basics
this is just going back to the basics
panel of us and this is not
an advanced or solar effect or anything
this is like the beginning of islam like
welcome to islam you got to teach this
because the prophet
islam said convey from me even even if
it's one ayah
so this is a a command from the prophet
to them if all you know is one verse in
the quran teach it
absolutely one verse but i think it's
important here
to refute you right so no
okay do you know this verse in arabic
can you recite this
verse you know off the top of your head
you know
you don't know arabic how can you you
know give dawah if you don't know arabic
okay you know have you studied akita
level 17
do you know the laws of inheritance like
these are the things you're gonna hear
you're gonna get passionate people like
yourselves who are masha'allah
you know conveying islam online and you
know people that say but you don't but
you don't
you don't know this you don't know that
the fact is is it
important for me to be a harvest of the
quran for me to be able to convey to my
neighbor
that allah does not have a son right
do i need that or do i just need the
basic
understanding of those verses so you
know alhamdulillah here in london
um you know you get all sorts of
experiences from people that have
accepted islam
i've met people who've accepted islam
while they were working in a bath and
the guy who was their manager was a
muslim
and you know he was talking to them by
islam and they both actually
in this haram industry and the muslim
carried on in that industry and the
non-muslim left
this isn't his say i have met this guy
at speaker's corner who
used to come there many years ago this
portuguese brother doesn't come there
anymore
you know you get these types of things
you get even situations where
you know a a a muslim
uh what's it called sister you know
like one one example that i do know of
is that there's this
uh sister this elderly uh pakistani
sister who basically uh she gave a copy
of the quran to her neighbor
and he was like what is this anyway
so he read it he accepted islam and he
goes around giving dawah like you get
these amazing stories of these average
people giving dawah
and then you get other people who were
literally oh is that guy giving dawah
let me just refute him with a bazooka
and i honestly think people are tools of
the shaitaan
they they aren't doing something
deliberately malicious
but they don't understand they actually
are tools of the shaitaan
and the shaitaan is using them to
actually stop
islam growing and you know shaytan's
very intelligent shaitaan's got
thousands of years of experience
we live for a lot what 50 60 years and
sadly we're falling into these traps
yeah fired do you have anything to uh to
jump in on here
i want to hear your thoughts it was
funny bro
as soon as you said that look who went
to the chat
the big man masha'allah
bro
so he would be probably very um he'll
probably have his own anecdotal
experience and
you know um wise words to add in sha
allah but until he gets in here
subhanallah
um
we want to answer your question do i
have anything in mind um
yeah first thing i wanted to say is
you're right bro when we were in class
we were learning that islam is a
complete way of life it's a complete
deen
and one of the biggest things that i'm
ashamed of today
in society is that forget non-muslims
aren't realizing that muslims themselves
don't realize
what an immense gift that we were born
into
yeah 100 bro
how you doing bro alhamdulillah
are you guys very good bro doing a
little better after you showed up
we were just talking about um the ummah
you remember yesterday's class we're
talking about what is islam and
everything
right and we talk about islam is not
just you know you pray and fast and you
believe in allah that's it
there's a layer to islam that's that
starts with the basics
right that people don't actually
understand which is this is a way and
in this way we do xyz it changes our
character
who we are as people the way we act and
in that we convey this beautiful
deen to people that's like islam 101.
we're just talking about how you know
also how we mentioned yesterday a lot of
people water down the deen to
we pray in the khalas that's it this is
exactly what we're talking about so
as as a reaver have you experienced
this level from muslims where one
there's a contention against you just
being a reaver you know having tattoos
and all this
or two a level where it's like you're a
revert already propagating islam where
born muslims are like i go to university
i pray dohar maybe on time and like
that's it
so what exactly are you asking bro
that was a loaded question yeah yeah
that was
so have you felt uh or experienced any
contention
since you became a muslim from the
muslims
uh can you use it in a sentence
contingency
contentions like so like uh basically
like has anyone kind of
attacked you or come against you because
you're a reaver ah
yes yes i've had uh
a lot of brothers and sisters
leave messages saying that um i need to
get rid of my tattoos now that i'm a
muslim
that allah doesn't love my tattoos i'm
like yeah i'm sure allah doesn't love it
but
i'm a reaver like my sins have been
you know washed away inshallah god
willing
and to get rid of all my tattoos like i
don't think people
understand how much money it takes and
how much pain
and time i have to go through like i
have to
i think it's well over fifty thousand
usd to get rid of all the tattoos that i
have and that's gonna take a span of
minimum 10 years i imagine what i could
do
with that much money to give back to
people
in this world just imagine bro how much
money like could be put into charity
and that could even go in to be building
a masjid
so i'm gonna choose getting rid of my
tattoos which allah
has already forgiven me for versus
actually building a mazda
doing charity actually benefiting this
dunya this world these are
these people not just the brothers and
sisters in the uma but
the humans in general like i i don't
know to me it's a very clear choice here
but
to other people they they attacked me
saying that oh brother allah does not
love their tattoos brother
ah that is what it is man
you know there's something uh
which we should all try and keep in mind
that
a person's um words
are a scoop of his heart they're like a
little sort of
flicker of what's going on so if i'm
sitting here
and you three guys are you know you
invite
you invited me on this podcast and
whatnot and you know
you guys are doing this voluntarily and
many people are learning about islam
and it's all this but then i just happen
to be fixated
on uh you know something trivial like oh
why did this start late you know that
type of thinking where you just focus on
something so
trivial and pathetic and new and you
forget the greater good
is a common disease and obviously it's
come out
in terms of this case in terms of your
tattoos or
with other people you know but the fact
is that
this is because we get our priorities
wrong
in all um in all of our discourses that
even we have online
how many times do we get it do we find
that muslims are arguing with each other
on very
petty issues and they treat these petty
issues like they are
really significant and sometimes they
refute each other as well on these
petty issues muhammad is a good way of
putting it he said it's the um
it's the narcissism of pettiness right
or it's the narcissism of small
difference right
and if we truly understood the value
of the dawah and what we can actually do
we would you know not be wasting our
times okay this guy did this let me fix
it i am sure any new muslim who
has tattoos or they had a previous
relationship or they have
a a habit which they find hard to kick
like drinking or whatnot i'm sure they
know what they need to do with their
life
right i'm pretty sure because they made
the choice to say
and they sacrificed the law so i don't
think they need a reminder in terms of
these other types of things
but it's because we don't fundamentally
understand islam and i do
think there is a huge responsibility
upon islamic teachers upon islamic
scholars upon imams upon community
leaders
upon influentials to actually go back to
basics
what is islam really about and can we
please get our priorities in order
i sometimes jump onto youtube and the
sort of discussions i see back and forth
i honestly think do people
actually think that this is beneficial
the amount of conversations that you
find like even
having this conversation with you
brother you know someone who messaged
you allah doesn't love your tattoos
i'm sure they should spend their time
doing a lot more productive things than
that
right um you know sometimes you get the
most
bizarrous things you know people being
fixated
on oh um you know uh brother you
brothers were out there giving bauer and
i noticed that you guys were wearing
your shoes
on but why do you do this and blah you
get you just people having
petty arguments about all these things
but fundamentally
if we truly understood this message and
we truly understood the power of this
message
we would be like an ambulance driver who
is driving to save his patient
and driving towards a hospital and if he
finds two hobos at the side of the
street that want to cobble with him
he'll ignore them he's not going to stop
the ambulance get out and start having
an argument
with these guys that's honestly how
muslims should be
they should have a sharp laser focus on
what they want to achieve
and get away from these you know these
absolute trivial issues
that's what i said that's awesome
last thing i want to jump in on here
because actually unfortunately i do have
to leave
um i do want to say that this is a
beautiful discussion and it's actually
very
very important so all the muslims
watching please reflect on this insha
allah and everything that brothers say
here today
i want to say that i believe it starts
with with a few things as we talked
about
going back to the basics learn islam and
learn it in the sense that you know
you're going to teach it
because we have this concept called uh
of yakken of certainty
in islam and they've actually done
studies there's something myself told me
about they've done studies that show
somebody when they're 100 certain of
doing something versus the person who's
99 percent sure
the entire like neurochemistry changes
in their brain the way their brain works
literally changes for that one percent
because there's a difference between
and most likely when you're searching
you're gonna teach islam and that's how
you're learning it
world difference and it's gonna do two
things it's gonna increase your
intellect your knowledge and two it's
gonna
change your character so you become that
person you become literally more like
the prophets
more like the sahaba and at the end of
the day if like when in doubt just
please when i look at when looking at a
revert remember
most of the great sahaba radhiallahu or
at least a lot of them
especially the greatest ones were all
reverts
not even was accepted as a kid
abu bakr umar uthman uh who fought
against muslims for so long
they became muslim as grown uh muslims
as grown men and then they they made
these worldwide changes
so with that of course i do have to go
may allah bless you all i love you all
for the sake of allah
uh inshallah look forward to speaking to
you guys soon
[Music]
yeah he's right though i mean like i
i will very often like look at what i'm
doing in my life and i'll be like oh man
i got so much on my plate i'm doing so
much right now
but then like when i really think about
it i'm like man look at look at the
prophet salallahu laid with southern
look at the companions like these were
proper men
like they did it all and they were on
dean and they were on islam this is
perfect like they were just
proper individuals and i'm like man like
i could you know what i'm not doing
enough actually i think i'm doing too
much no no i'm not doing enough
compared to these men so i gotta step it
up a notch
oh
and i got to say bro before you even go
in you got a very peaceful vibe
and may allah bless you brother that's
not the way atheists feel about me
though hey it is what it is man
it is what it is you know what's
interesting
is um if if we look at
football right i'm not sure if you guys
are football fans but
i'm sure you know about football fans
you know you get
football fans who literally will argue
with each other
all day you know my team is better than
yours we only lost because you know our
guy was on sick leave or
you know this goalkeeper as a seller
whatever it is
and people have these debates why
because they believe in the team they
believe in something
that's greater than them and there's an
interesting psychology to this that
human beings we need
an immortality project right
basically we need an idea or a
philosophy or
something which is greater than
ourselves so we can attach
ourselves to that which is why what you
find is that some people find that in
nationalism they're very nationalistic
some people find that in joining you
know
a particular ideology like communism
other people they make human rights into
a type of religion and they just become
activists and you know that's their main
thing you know
the nazis uh were one extreme example of
that where you know people started
believing in
you know this type of ideology and were
willing to give up everything for it
so human beings need this immortality
project something greater than
themselves
they need you know this idea that
there's something
beyond me i'm one cog in this giant
thing but i am
part of something greater and islam
that's what it does it teaches you
you are not alone you
are part of the legacy of ibrahim you
are part of the
legacy of the muslims who are going to
exist hundreds of years from now
you know what you are doing today is
because of the work of the people
previously to you and what you are doing
today is planting the seeds for the
people of the future
and you know that transcendence that's
what we really want to feel and you know
you spoke about not not doing enough for
the deen
you know i believe one of the ways to
drive yourself
to do more for the religion is actually
by studying islamic history
and actually studying the spread of
islam is looking at
not only the stories of the prophets you
know going back to how ibrahim al-islam
was a young man
he had to go against all of his
societies throw thrown into the fire
and you know the fire became cool to him
but go
all the way to you know how did how did
all these muslims appear in central asia
how did the mongols become muslim you
know how is it that you have
um han chinese uh people who are muslim
how is it that we have hui muslims how
do we how is it that we have
these uh muslims how did the people of
the hausa
uh the hausa people uh in northern
nigeria how do they accept islam when
you start looking into these you're like
allahu akbar
there is an amazing history here and
that will drive you forward to take more
actions as well
that's interesting because we had um
we had doctor steph carys on a few times
you know the brother yes yes of course
yeah masha allah may allah bless him
but he's got such a profound knowledge
on islamic history
and um you know what now that i'm like
retracing the steps like he he pretty
much says the same thing
and he says how important the the
knowledge of the history is
for muslims to study like it's not just
like a history lesson it's not like oh
we're in school where classes in session
here
this is what happens so you know so
history doesn't repeat itself no no
it's so you know even further so you can
become a better muslim so you can
give more from your part
you know so i i really like that i
really do
absolutely 100
100 which reminds me man we gotta have
doctors steph curry's back
so um there was uh
one main thing that i wanted to ask you
so
from the debate that i found you right
with cosmic skeptic about
objective morality right how would you
define objective morality
to a lay man somebody who's like you
know what does that mean objective
morality isn't there just normal
morality
right good question um
so what i would say is by
pointing out the opposite so i would say
to them
that you liking a particular ice cream
flavor
so if you like you know strawberry or
raspberry or mango or goofy or whatever
it is you like a particular thing
is that something which is
true is that something like this is the
best flavor is that just your opinion
is that just you know your preference
they'll say no me liking a particular
ice cream flavor
is just my preference now if someone
else turns around and says no actually i
really like vanilla ice cream
you know somebody else a judge can't
come in between somebody who likes mango
ice cream and vanilla ice cream and say
he is correct and you are wrong because
these are preferences
there is no right or wrong in
preferences these are just
subjective um you know opinions we hold
what if i was to say to the person well
in the same
manner what if somebody considered
that killing
stealing you know kicking old people
just
any random evil is
actually just as
meaningless just as subjective just
a preference in the same way that
you know we like a particular ice cream
flavor so whether you want to give
charity to a homeless person or kick a
homeless person if you want to do
good or you know do bad it's like
vanilla and it's like mango
you know it's it's preferences people
have and the
normal reaction that people are going to
have is an aversion to that they're
going to be quite disgusted by that
they're going to be like
no something's not right about that you
know
there's something true you know helping
somebody who's poor
as opposed to hurting them helping them
is good
this is bad this isn't a preference
thing this isn't a flavor thing this
isn't a subjective thing
there is something objective about it
another way of putting it is you know
someone says well i like you know
vanilla and somebody else says i like
mango and i'm like
i like one plus one equaling five
and my maths teacher says is one plus
one is two but you know that's just his
preference
again someone will say no these are two
different things
so choosing a flavor of the ice cream is
again subjective but
your opinion about one plus one is five
or someone else thinks one plus one is
minus seven that's irrelevant to the
truth that one plus one is two
there is an objective truth out there
which is independent
of your subjective ideas your
preferences
so morality from
a atheistic view from a materialistic
view from the idea that there is no god
is as meaningless and as
baseless as someone's preference for a
flavor of ice cream
that's pretty disturbing it's especially
disturbing because the loudest people on
earth today
who point the finger at religious people
and say
you are immoral your religion is immoral
are actually people who are atheist
and they use the morality card probably
the most although
interestingly enough the most brutal
people in the history of the world
have been atheists like chairman mao and
stalin and lenin and paul paul and
you know all of these despots were
atheists they they were
you know people who even xi jinping the
current you know dictator in china you
know all of the
horrible things he's doing he's an
atheist as well so you know even though
atheists have been
the most cruelest in history and in
terms of pure stats
the amount of people they've killed have
in just the last hundred years
has far outstripped all the people that
were killed in
all of the religious wars in human
history right
the atheists in one century alone have
killed more people than all the
religious people in human history
yet they want to point the finger at us
buy something that they cannot justify
so you know the whole discussion started
off with cosmic skeptic
by something very simple i made a video
in which i said human rights
is something atheists should not speak
about because human rights do not exist
because morality does not exist it's
just a preference
he took that video and he made a
response
and then once he made the response i'm
somebody who
i don't believe in and you you guys
probably noticed this right
you get these online atheists right who
make these videos
with pictures and animation and good
lighting i mean look at us
we look possessed you know bad lighting
and this and that
you get these people with amazing
looking
you know studios and this and that and
they're talking and they're very
scripted
and i've always seen those people
crumble
when you bring them face to face and you
challenge them directly
so that's what my intention was and
that's not my intention with only him
but any atheist
you know someone who tries to say this
or that i don't like going back and
forth and making response videos i'm
like all right bring it on let's have a
discussion live
so that's how the discussion began and
it ended up
uh you know as a debate at the oxford
university
of the point home further bro it's like
anyone listening guys and girls it's
like it's like stealing
you know it's wrong even if you're doing
it you can justify you can rationalize
it like oh i need the money or
you know god will understand me it's
like no you know what's wrong
right and the the point you touched on
with subjective morality it's almost
like
we live in a godless society where i
hear phrases like it doesn't align with
my truth
okay what is your truth though well it
doesn't align with my
feelings my intuition what is that where
do you draw the line between subjective
and objective right so
that's something people people got to
know however i just ask
everybody to consider some of the
popular atheists online right
uh the guys with those nice studios and
those nice
uh you know animation and all this
effort
watch those guys in their studios when
they're talking with confidence and
power and energy and passion and all of
this drive
and watch them when they are speaking to
the brothers life
or if if they're in debates and that's
the thing that you find that
you know when these people are making
their videos on their own
they try and come across as you know
being really assertive and confident
but you know when the truth goes against
falsehood
falsehood comes on its knees and
you see it live so you know i would say
that
you obviously brought up one youtuber i
would say
you know whenever these types of people
appear
uh these types of militant atheists um
and even these militant christians like
david wood you know
he's honest i'm sure you guys seen the
debate with uh
hijab but before his debate you know i
used to just
disguise to come up on my live stream uh
that's uh on on the
you know your youtube whatever it is and
the guy used to be like
talking with so much confidence and
energy and passion
but then with hijab he was just like he
was like a
kid getting bullied and while he was
diamond
sorry you're talking about hammer time
or who yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's talking about hamilton you know you
just watch that debate between hijab
and david wood and look at his body
language
and and the way that he's speaking and
the tone of his voice and his
nervousness and that's the thing that's
the thing that
when you get these people there is such
a discrepancy between the confidence
they show
when they're in their comfortable room
making videos
and when they actually have to go toe to
door toe to toe with muslims
because at the end of the day you know
whether it's the field of buddha
or it's an online discussion the truth
comes out
you know people get rattled people
actually
really you see them crumble before the
uh this sort of arguments are being made
and you also find that when you have
iman when you have faith when you have
this
drive you see that
come across whether you're in a nice lit
studio
or you're in a live discussion at
speaker's corner on a live thing
but these guys are artificial they have
to create this type of artificial
environment to make themselves look a
particular way
you know i was laughing at these um you
know that apus guy
uh he came on to the um uh
thought adventure podcast it was
horrible i mean i got second-hand
embarrassment
for watching that and what if you watch
his videos on his own you know he's
talking like this with
you know so much energy and this and
that and you would think that this guy
is a flipping lion
you know this guy needs to be you know
he you know we need to protect
ourselves from him but then when he
comes out
he's a toothless animal he's just
literally like
you know i don't understand and in the
middle of talking to daniel akiko
that the guy is almost having like an
anxiety attack like
don't don't pretend to be a world-class
you know boxer or fighter and then turn
up in the ring
and then you just look like a flipping
anorexic pensioner
yeah you need to you know uh
i can tell brother uh angel that you're
from a background that
people call your bluff right people can
tell if your talk matches your actions
right with these online guys it doesn't
um no isn't that right angel
yeah yeah i'm just playing on a side
note honest i know uh
my name is pronounced angel angel
why did you say that because
yeah but most people they butcher it so
i i don't even get upset
but brother i got two things man i got
two things so number one
with david wood ask fired
ask romney well we did a reaction video
with uh
sheikh uh uthman even farooq
and uh just when he was talking with
david wood and with
all the other the the little squad that
they had the trinity
the trinity oh god the trinity all right
we'll call the trinity
but the the thing that i said i did not
say this but i said
i said look look at his body language
look at his body language and it's like
bro as the the conversation progressed
you see the shake and he remains in the
same frame
it doesn't change it's it's the same and
then
you see david when i was only focused on
david wood so i only brought attention
to that
but every time that this was going on
like as the
conversation went on and on you saw the
anxiety
arising you saw the insecurity arising
and it's just like oh man like that's
that's sad man and then number two he
was talking about apus and
how he uh he's basically you said a
toothless animal
into this animal am i correct yeah yeah
yeah bro he um
i think fayad has sent it to me but he
had
i think he put a post or something where
he said that
he's uh pretty much put every single
muslim in their place
or like no one stood a chance against
him like he he said that he
he said he made muhammad hijab look like
he was nothing or something like that
i'm like bro what is this guy like
where is he at right now like what's
going on in his head
yeah it's like yeah all right sit down
have a sandwich yeah well done
his analysis is brilliant you know
someone could say with some level of
plausibility
that apus is
potentially a muslim who wants to
discredit
the ex-muslim movement so he's
pretending to be an ex-muslim
i mean if someone was to make that
argument i would say hmm
i said you've got maybe you're onto
something there
oh like i'm actually pretty happy that
he's
the most popular ex-muslim online
like it's like okay you know that's
that's the guy that that's you know
that's what you want people to come
towards yeah man
i mean i'm glad man like that's that's
the best that the explosion community
could do
where did he get that name by the way
apus
muhammad hijab was calling him puss
elena
instead of calling him a person he
started calling him apus
and then what happened is over time
everybody forgot
his name and they started calling him
apos and then
in his discussion and that's the thing
how how ridiculous
uh this guy is if you're in a discussion
something pees you off
right you're gonna debate and something
somebody says really pees you off
you never ever show your cards you don't
show them
that that's something that irritates you
but apus
in the debate you know he's like don't
call me apost it's like
all right if you in the debate are going
to throw a tantrum and say don't call me
apost
then muhammad hijab the next word out of
his mouth is going to be
apos relax or april's whatever like he
doesn't understand basic psychology he
doesn't understand
basics of debating plus listen i'm
telling you right in front of you
don't call me apus okay debating is not
you know you don't just say whatever you
feel
you know it's it's an arena it's it's a
place
where you gotta you know you gotta
battle you gotta put on your battle face
you gotta
you know use certain tactics you gotta
trap your opponent you gotta do certain
things
you gotta be aware of his attack and
then your counter attack and you know
and you know i look at i mean
alhamdulillah
i i spend a lot of time looking at
debates and you know
how how they happen and then you look at
people apostate you're literally like
in a the equivalent of a street fight
between
you know people like april's david wood
and then hijab and others
is is literally like you know a
bulldozer versus you know an ostrich egg
it's there's no competition
and you sometimes think you know in
movies and i'm sure you guys
know this if in the movie the hero
doesn't take some beating before he wins
if the hero just looks into an area
beats the crap out of everybody
but never goes through some pain or that
like
superman has kryptonite or batman you
know he he sometimes
looks like he's losing you know that
makes the movie more interesting because
it's kind of like
all right the hero's about to lose or
the hero's wounded and then he comes
back
as an undug dog just right at the last
moment and wins
you know it always makes us you know oh
wow when these debates we don't get to
see that
we just see a way mauling we just see a
one mission and you sometimes think
maybe you should have been a bit more
you know forced
and it's like habib how he was just
mauling all his opponents but um
it kind of raises the question like
how big of an ego do these individuals
really have
you know because like if you get a
proper muslim like let's say you give
mohammed a job
all right he's having a discussion with
someone listen i don't know the brother
i know he's a muslim though i know he's
probably i know he's he's
well well like up here he's studying
he's academic
all right you get him in a debate if
something comes up
well mohammad jab genuinely doesn't know
i'm sure he's not gonna just try to like
make this bluff and like just go on with
some running live like oh
this is this and this is that and try to
act like he knows what he's talking
about when
he genuinely doesn't know he'll probably
be like oh i don't know
i'll have to get back to you on that but
you get people that have these big
eagles these atheists
and it's like they genuinely don't know
what they're talking about
but their ego is so strong and so
inflated that they're like nah nah nah
i can't let this go i can't let this go
yeah that's an interesting point you
raise because you know
in a debate or a discussion if someone
says something you don't understand
you can just say all right fair enough
well that's it that's the easiest way of
dealing with that but like you said what
other people do is they start digging a
hole and i've noticed there's a
speaker's corner in dealing with some of
these militant atheists
they'll dig a hole you notice they're
digging a hole
they don't know that you've noticed yeah
like laurence krauss
yeah and they just keep digging and then
by the time you point out to them they
actually about
10 foot under and they're staring up at
you like oh damn
like i i if i if someone pointed that
out like a minute ago i would have
realized that i'm actually shooting
myself in the foot
and especially one thing which i like to
do
in philosophy one of the golden medals
if you like
is to show a self-contradiction and
that's something which i really like
doing with
these militant atheists because you know
if you
show that they are self-contradictory
that they aren't actually saying
something coherent because they
disagreed with themselves somewhere else
um i mean it's just an own goal
right so that's one of the things which
i think in the dawa as well
if you're having these types of formal
debates
uh muslim muslims should be utilizing
more
i also don't um and this is my
sort of advice uh to people who want to
get into this
if you're dealing with an average person
average atheist average non-muslim
you be nice polite kind gentle
you know all of those things but what
we're here speaking about is
islamophobes and militant atheists and
you know these types of antitheists
so that's why you get that sort of
battle
sometimes some muslims they think okay
that means everyone's treated that way
which is not true at all these
discussions are with a
niche group of people and the average
person that you're debating a non-muslim
about god or this or that
you know you have to have a totally
different demeanor right
um and i think that's very important to
highlight because some people
just don't make the distinction which is
why i sometimes get worried about some
of these
you know high tension debates that take
place in the repercussions of them
because some people can just
misunderstand totally
that that's not the way you talk to an
average person
so with that being said if the two
questions i have well is one merged into
two
but um how would people go about
handling
atheists that aren't militant and then
how would they go about handling the
atheists that are militant
okay so the first thing to know is in
your
if you're dealing with a militant
atheist
i mean by militant atheist is somebody
who is a brutalist
evangelist not just someone who has
strong views on atheism
i don't mean that meaning that
and i would say for the average what do
you mean by evangelists as in they would
promote it
they would ridicule religion they would
actively
um you know be a representative of it
which is why
the vast majority of muslims will never
really interact though we interact with
those types of militant atheists right
the type of atheist they will interact
with is just somebody who
doesn't believe in god has strong views
on that so with them you're gentle
you're kind you're trying to bring them
around you're trying to be sympathetic
at the same time you're saying to them
look islam has
this belief that you don't believe in
god and we believe belief in god is
natural and rational and if you do
believe in god
this is what you get if you don't
believe in god these are the
consequences in your
you you're direct and clear with them
but you know
formal debates have a very niche purpose
which are done by select group of people
and they should never transfer into your
common
your common discourse online and offline
and i think that's a
huge danger which is why uh the sort of
discussions that we
see um uh
the good discussions that we see in in
speaker's corner where
mansoor and harsham will take this
atheist and they'll sit on the floor
on the grass and they'll discuss or you
know you get these other youtubers who
are having these really pleasant
conversations on the street in leicester
square
in new york other places they're giving
out food or donuts or other stuff and
they're having discussions
um you know all that stuff is wonderful
because that is the average person that
you're going to be interacting with
[Music]
so how are they going to deal with those
that are
coming real strong the evangelists
well i would say that you know you
you have to understand their world view
quite thoroughly and then break it down
[Music]
i would highly advise right and i've
seen this myself
some people get into these discussions
with these militant atheists
and they don't know what they're talking
about the muslims don't know what
they're talking about
or they know what they're talking about
but they
don't have the debating skills
to actually come across quite well to
actually articulate and
they even though they may be making
valid points it looks like they're
losing
because they just don't know how to talk
right
so i would advise that if you are to
tackle an atheist on any issue
say you having a debate of some sort
you need to understand their worldview
better than them
you need to have plan a plan b plan c
you need to have this
inter interweb of okay if they say this
then you're going to say this if they
say this if you're going to say this if
they bring this
thing that you haven't heard of then
what you're going to do now you have to
plan it
all out like a strategy after all you
know you have to think of it as
a grand plan you know um
if you go into like obviously we don't
say that these mixed martial arts are
halal
in any way however you know if you
if you are watching um you know
a fight a brutal fight between two
people
one guy just wants to punch the other
guy with his right arm and that's his
main thing that he wants to do no matter
what the other guy is doing this guy's
just trying to punch
him with his right hand that's it you
know that that guy is going to lose
that guy's going to lose why because
he's got one plan
and that's all he wants to do the other
guy is evolving adapting
changing he is he's like water he's
flowing and seeing where are the
opportunities where are the threats what
do i do
right and that person is way more likely
to win
because he's got all of these different
strategies how do you get that in a
militant debate debate between
a muslim and say a militant atheist well
you have to understand
and have a deep understanding of their
worldview so then you can know all of
the different things that you can do
and don't and this is very important you
know back in the days i used to watch
wrestling
and i used to be a big fan of bcw and
you know all these types of things
and they used to you know these other
wrestlings or platforms used to have
this thing
don't try this at home do you guys
remember that it used to be those things
like you know
because you know people stop doing pile
drivers through
you know sofas and you know all these
things
you know i remember doing a somersault
and uh
you know breaking the sofa
in my front front living room you know
people do all sorts of crazy
so these debates that you see online
between
say a militant atheist or one like hijab
or whatever
some people think okay i've seen that
let me go find somebody and let me
repeat that
again don't try this at home you really
need to know what you're doing
and i'd recommend books like hamza's
book the divine reality
but never ever go into a a discussion
like this unless you really know what
you're doing
bro quick question are you pakistani
yes okay
um maybe a longer answer to this
question
of all the issues and cancers that
you've been talking about in the ummah
today
right not with islam but with the
muslims that we see today in our
approach to giving dawah
one main issue that i've been seeing
left right and center is
this unhealthy obsession to nationalism
and i think that every single person to
some degree
if they're just programmed and they
don't really unplug from
from their you know software settings so
to speak they they carry out this
this then they exercise this nationalism
so
what is what is this all about how do we
tackle this what are the
issues with with nationalism okay very
good i would say again let's go back to
discussing iman
discussing islam people are
understanding islam
you know when we look at these nation
states
and the borders right we need to ask
ourselves the question
does iman does faith have
borders no
faith doesn't have borders so we should
be happy and comfortable
and say yes i'm pakistani i'm sudanese
i'm bangladeshi
i'm turkish i'm algerian um fijian or
whatever
but you should never ever believe that
your country
is better than another country you know
a pakistani should happily say you know
i love bangladesh i love afghanistan
sudan
turkey whatever and you know these types
of tribalistic
uh tendencies which we do have you know
they are toxic they are literally toxic
because
you know where does it end it doesn't
just end with say a pakistani
nationalist right may think they're
better than a
bangladeshi or an indian or an afghan or
an afghan may think they're better than
whatever right uh like we had this
you know during world war uh one where
you had this turkish nationalism and
arab nationalism
this type of thing but then when you go
to the country itself
are they all the same people you go to
pakistan it's called bhutan's
right uh it's called punjabis got
balochis sindhis mahajas rohingya
bangladeshis you know all these
different types of people then it's
going to be like well
you know i don't like punjabis or i
don't like protons or i don't like this
and
then where do you stop and then when
you're within
one group of people like say the pratans
then amongst the batons they'll be like
yeah but they're from the afridi tribe
or they're from
you know this ahmazai tribe or whatever
and then it's just okay then it's
you know more and more tribalism and you
find this you know in muslim countries
you find that if this
nationalism is not curtailed then it
turns into tribalism which muslims are
each other's
throats are even the tribal level
even the district level right you know
for example if you go to pakistan you
have a different culture in lahore to
karachi to you know these types of
things
as muslims all of this is garbage all of
this is
absolute nonsense right you
should be proud of being a muslim and
if you have a love for your country i'm
not saying that's a bad thing
if you love your food and you believe
your food is better than others
right you know and and it's done in this
very light-hearted way like oh our food
is better than yours or
you know you have this sometimes
discussion among south asians who has
the best dal
you know a light-hearted way who you
know who cares that stuff is fine
but this type of nationalism is a
disease
is something which we should openly
speak up against
and we should openly um address this
question uh to the new muslims as well
and say to them look
when you come to islam you will get this
you will get some muslims
who you know think they're better than
others because they're from a certain
country
we should know this is not part of islam
at all because iman
has no borders
[Music]
that's true i got a question
it's a little off topic but you have
mentioned speaker's corner a lot
how often are you at speaker's corner
um i've been going speaker's corner
for about 11 years now
and i don't go as regularly as i used to
but i still watch the stuff right i i
would like to go more often
um but you know work commitments
other things come up and stuff um but
the reason why i love it
is because it's like a battle of ideas
right if everyone brings their ideas to
the table and then it's like all right
let's see who wins
and the people you meet in speaker's
corner i'm not normal people
you know you sometimes come across
tourists and others who are like normal
people and you discuss with them but
usually
you get very opinionated strong debaters
and everyone's there to just
have a debate and discussion and if two
people
spoke to each other in speaker's corner
and agreed i reckon everyone would just
ignore them the reason why people love
it is because two people come together
and there's a spark
where they argue and they disagree and
they go toe-to-toe
and i think i don't know why but i've
always been attracted to that type of
you know that type of uh environment
it's like it's like fighting but it's
like mental fighting it's like
intellectual
i mean yeah exactly he would think
ah yeah like my plan is aligned with the
loss plan because everything is
functioning so
smoothly but then out of nowhere there's
a sticking point
and like nothing's happening and to him
he's like
going crazy and he he's pretty much
second out or second-guessing doubting
and uh just chaotic for like a better
words
but it's in that time where he needs to
be as patient as possible
and continue to trust in the creator and
continue to do
whatever it is he started doing keeping
the same energy that he started with
in order for him to pass the test
[Music]
[Music]
um